ich würde gerne über italien sprechen in
italien haben wir jetzt plötzlich eine
übermacht von jungen afrikanern und
jungen männern aus den maghreb staaten
die den gardasee
erobert haben und es auch genau so
nennen vergangenen donnerstag kam haben
2000 junge männer eine badeort gestürmt
haben frauen belästigt haben randaliert
und wir sind in deutschland nicht
vorbereitet auf so etwas wir können
eigentlich nur von glück reden dass es
uns in den letzten jahren nicht so
erwischt hat aber der gardasee hat jetzt
seine eigene kölner domplatte und
genaugenommen diskutiert jetzt italien
das integrationsproblem dass wir in
deutschland auch haben und was wir jetzt
seit vielen jahren konsequent vor uns
herschieben und es würde mich nicht
wundern wenn wir das im sommer als
problem auch bekommt jedes mal wenn so
ein ereignis ist schweigen in
deutschland die meisten medien man hat
hier gar nicht viel mitbekommen weil es
die falschen täter sind wir diskutieren
lieber über gender sterne und über die
schuld des alten weißen mannes die
bekommen in europa aber gerade ein
problem mit dem jungen schwarzen und ich
würde gerne darüber reden ohne dass man
sofort immer mit der keule kommt das sei
rechts der islamophobie oder sonst was
wir haben letztes wochenende auch in
düsseldorf wir haben in stuttgart wir
haben junge männer banden genau mit
demselben profil die durch die stadt
laufen die allah akbar rufen dass es
kein freundschaftlicher gruß und ich
denke deutschland ist jetzt so weit dass
wir endlich eine integrationsdebatte
führen und zwar in einem tenor die
bedeutet dass integration eine
bringschuld ist und nicht etwas was wir
als deutsche leist frau keller ich würde
hier direkt ein haken vergessen sie bei
dem plädoyer nicht dass jeden zweiten
oder dritten tag wird eine frau von
ihrem partner getötet also wenn wir über
gewalt an frauen und hassan frauen reden
dann können wir eigentlich nicht sagen
dass sie importiert ist das paradies
ohne gewalt gab es nicht vor den
flüchtlingen weil sich hier noch
ergänzen möchte wenn wir nur über die
migrationswelle reden es ist dann nicht
eigentlich für die deutschen weißen
männer die frauen feine sind ganz toll
wenn wir die gar nicht mehr erwähnen
wird schieben ist alles auf die
flüchtlinge und sagen die importieren
uns die gewalt an frauen aber ist gewalt
an frauen nicht ein viel größeres thema
als das zum beispiel am gardasee ich
würde gerne differenzieren wollen was
jetzt genau das machen wo wir die
debatte jedes mal erstickt wird indem
man sagt ja aber der deutsche mann ist
doch auch gewalt tja das mag sein aber
ich kann ihnen sagen schon damals nach
der kölner domplatte irgendwie alsmann
tage braucht um überhaupt zur kenntnis
zu nehmen was da passiert ist bis heute
halt hält sich der mythos nach dem motto
das kennen wir doch das würde auch immer
auf dem oktoberfest stand finden und so
weiter ich kann ihnen sagen in ganz
europa hat es so etwas nicht gegeben
dass tausende tausende wir sprechen hier
nicht davon von von häuslicher gewalt
die gibt es wahrscheinlich leider
weltweit aber sondern dass im
öffentlichen raum junge männer die ganz
offensichtlich nichts zu tun haben
randalieren frauen begrapschen frauen
vergewaltigen soso einer herren der
hieraus angebot an farmville ist gucken
sie sich die die die polizeistatistik an
ich würde er einfach gerne
differenzieren die verschiedenen
straftaten die datierung der anzahl
wichtig wie viel prozent sind das die
migrationshintergrund an dass die gewalt
an frauen wenn sie sagen dass mit
importiert gewalt auf der straße ist
glaube ich irgendwie irgendwo bei 70
prozent kann man bestimmt sagen also
auch die
ich habe nicht immer einig würde nein
aber diese eine solche ereignisse als
wieder haben das junge wenn er sich
zusammenrotten um gezielt zu randalieren
um tatsächlich und sie haben sich
gesammelt unter einem hashtag den ich
sehr spannend finde nämlich an afrika in
pescara und demnächst irgendwie afrika
sonst was das heißt sie haben ganz
gezielt gebrüllt auch slogans das ist
polizei dokumentiert in italien weiße
frauen haben hier nichts zu suchen das
skandierten diese jungen männer am
gardasee unschuldige sehe so etwas kenne
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht von
europäischen jungen zum thema statistik
ja es ist sagen wir da wird auch nicht
ordentlich registriert was wann wie
passiert die polizei ist ja auch schon
die correctness gebunden sonst kommt ja
sofort unter das profil das wie nennt
man das sozialressort
profine enthalten sie nicht dass vor
allem mädchen und bei gewalt berichtet
wird mir weil ich auf jeden fall weil
sie meinen sie mal
amt ist nicht meines ist das
bundeskriminalamt dann können sie den
chef des bundes gewarnt als fragen am
ende
dreimal in der woche finden in der
bundesrepublik gruppenvergewaltigung
statt diese gruppen vergewaltigung wenn
wir ausschließlich können wir stecken ja
öffentlich aber im deutschen bundestag
von flüchtlingen dieckow die
ausländische neubürger willkommenskultur
gemäss als
geschmacksträger keinen fall schon sagst
du weißt genau wir sicher nicht wirklich
wahrhaben dass also dreimal in der woche
finden straftaten in einer dimension
stadt die gab es früher auch aber nicht
in diesem ausmaß und dazu möchte ich
aber sagen was sie nun erstaunt wird
erstaunen wird wissen sie wir holen uns
eine kultur ins land und sagen wir
wollen ja nicht mal mehr integrieren
denn wir verfolgen er den ansatz die
welt ist eine welt für alle menschen und
die menschen die eben integration wollen
heißt doch wieder körner kolonialismus
nein jeder soll sich so hier fühlen wie
er sich zu hause bei sich fühlt und dann
müssen wir auch diese kultur hat mir
nicht achten und wenn ich ihnen sage in
den staaten aus denen die kommen
passiert so was die als täglicher sind
vergewaltiger oder wie wenn sie es aus
deutete über dämlich was ich jetzt sagen
gegen die straftaten begehen reichen mir
schon es müssen nicht alle seien bereits
schon dieser ausschnitt
und das ist also die die folge auch dass
wir kein verständnis für deren kultur
aufbringen verstehen sie wenn bei uns
die frauen die fleischbeschau
am haken halb nackt durch die straßen
gehen im sommer dann stoßen wir auf ein
verständnis bei denen das sie freiwild
sind die frauen dort sind verhüllt das
mag ich nicht mag man nicht mögen ich
finde zum beispiel erotisch burka wenn
diese erotisch aber andere stelle setze
sie immer wieder so ein super sexy dress
man muss halt etwas zu entdecken so und
du hast müssen also jede meinung aber
sie finden die burka sie wissen die burg
heißt nicht dass kopf hat die mutter ist
die realistisch wir genau dieses thema
zu ernst
wir reden hier immerhin über straftat
liegen wird frau ich viele male in den
staaten des nahen ostens und habe mich
mit leuten dort unterhalten männern und
frauen nicht alle frauen empfinden das
als unterdrückung und das auch mal ganz
klar zu sagen wir maßen uns an mit
unserem kulturbegriff durch die gegend
zu ziehen und anderen vorzuschreiben wie
sie hier zählt
es geht um die frage was in europa noch
mal dass wir nicht zu ende sicher in
ihrem sinne wir haben die polizei greife
nicht ein in köln hat sie nicht
eingegriffen in berlin haben die ich
kenne genug polizisten haben die angst
das ist disziplinarverfahren kriegen
wenn sie zugreifen weil natürlich
überall beobachtet die polizei sind
irgendwelche grün und welche anderen
männer dieser rumrennen und die polizei
beobachten ist in ländern wo anders
durchgegriffen wird ist natürlich bei
sich zu hause machen die das nicht punkt
zwei ist nur werden sie nämlich bestraft
bei sich zu hause sehen das machen wir
sehr hart es gab wie zum beispiel den
linden
gruppenvergewaltigung also den schon
jetzt
natürlich unter gewaltigen weil ja
gesagt wurde in den heimatländern machen
sie es nicht nur die waren also in der
abenstein und hat sie sich an die zettel
holen aber
das
würde ich nicht beschreiben die zahlen
sagen
leitungsteam schien sich das
problem ist um zu quatschen also
lasst doch sagen hallo kein einziger
mann hat in köln einmal frau geholfen
das gibt es in keinem anderen land auch
nicht den arabischen
sozusagen ihrer männlichkeit müssen sie
sich schämen männlichkeit den sieben top
stars vom erde heraus wollen frauen
schätzen ich glaube wirklich dass das
thema zu ernst ist und ich glaube ich
würden dieses thema nicht in die
lächerlichkeit da hab ich nicht gelassen
aber natürlich schon eine frage ist ist
ich habe mich dann jetzt da heute
natürlich auch mit dem fall eingelesen
ich glaube es ist die situation ja so
dass es überwiegend schon um die zweite
generation ging zumindest die festnahmen
ist glaube ich 30 leute sind ja
festgenommen worden
belegen zumindest dass es schon zweiter
generation ist die italienische
staatsangehörige und das ist doch
eigentlich die frage die wir haben wir
müssen sozusagen und da gebe ich sogar
in gewisser weise recht integration ist
was was wir einfordern müssen und wir
müssen auch in gewisser weise
konsequenter werden wenn zum beispiel
gegen strafrecht verstoßen wird deswegen
haben wir doch jetzt auch und da glaube
ich es vor allem meine partei auch ein
korrektiv in der bundesregierung zb die
debatte über den abschiebe beauftragten
wir wollen auch dahin gehen dass wir
wieder mehr abschieben wenn ich mir
jetzt in berlin anschauen wir haben ja
hier das unglück rot grün rot regiert zu
werden da passiert sowas einfach auch
nicht wenn ich natürlich keine
konsequenzen zeige auf straftaten
auffiel verhalten da brauche ich mich
nicht wundern dass ich es mache aber wir
müssen in der diskussion definitiv
differenziert dass sein wir müssen
genauer hingucken und nur pauschal zu
sagen es sind einwanderer aus nordafrika
stimmt halt nicht weil es wie gesagt
italienische staatsangehörige was was
diese über diese jungen männer alle eint
ist leider tatsächlich auch einfach die
herkunft auch aus einem islamischen
kulturkreis und wir wissen was ich meine
ich wunder mich immer darüber wie mit
zweierlei maß gemessen wird in der frage
der frauenrechte in der frage der
übergriffe auf frauen man muss ja nur
einfach mal das gedankenexperiment zu
lassen stellen sie sich mal vor
irgendwie auch nur 100 deutsche männer
würden irgendwie durch die straßen
ziehen oder würden in einem zugwaggon
über über fünf frauen herfallen und sie
vergewaltigen was in diesem land los
wäre ja oder auch auf die kölner
domplatte können sie sich einfach mal in
einer anderen kulturellen situation
vorstellen dass das nicht männer mit
migrationshintergrund gewesen wären
sondern deutsche männer was hätten wir
für eine debatte wir diskutieren über
jedes falsche wort eines deutschen
landes aber hier haben wir einfach der
haben tatsächlich einfach eine
zuwanderung als einem kulturkreis die
die frau anders sieht so und damit
müssen wir endlich umgehen und das
müssen wir offen benennen weil wir sonst
nämlich gerade auch die zweite
generation der jungen männer nicht in
den griff bekommen das ist ja auch ein
versagen des elternhauses offensichtlich
haben die elternhäuser ja überhaupt kein
problem damit dass die das waren 16 17
jährige junge männer die da randalierend
auf den straßen sind wo sind da
eigentlich die eltern offensichtlich
hatten wird das gutgeheissen und
offensichtlich wird das in die nächste
generation so weiter getragen das heißt
dieses problem wird vergrößert nicht
verkleinert und in dem man so tut als
gäbe ist das problem nicht oder indem
man das klein redet oder vergleich nach
dem motto ja aber die anderen haben auch
straftaten ja aber lasst uns doch bitte
um beide lasst uns um alle probleme
kümmern ja um die probleme die der
deutsche mann verursacht gegenüber der
frau aber bitteschön gerade diese männer
mit zuwanderungsgeschichte mit einem
wirklich mittelalterlichen frauenbild um
wir müssen wir uns kümmern und die
brauchen konsequenzen die brauchen
strafen so können sich nicht um ein kind
erziehen